おはようございます。
今日もプリティーシリーズの最新ニュースをお伝えします。
6月6日土曜日の情報を中心に、注目のイベントや新商品、キャンペーン情報をわかりやすくお届けします。
まずはオネガイアイプリからのニュースです。
明日6月6日から、ゲーム機オネガイアイプリのあるお店で、サンリオキャラクターズとのコラボキャンペーンがスタートします。
今回のプレゼントはおりびあ おねがいパティシエール ポムポムプリンのスペシャルオアイプリカードです。
小学生以下のかたには特別にセーブカードもプレゼントされます。
ただし、数に限りがありますので、欲しいかたはお早めにどうぞ。
おりびあちゃんのバズリウムコーデのカードや、ぐみちゃんとのデュオコーデカードも注目されています。
ゲームの最新バージョンオネガイアイプリ2だんは6月4日から稼働中で、ますます盛り上がっています。
また、アニメオネガイアイプリも見逃せません。
公式ユーチューブチャンネルアイプリちゅ～ぶでは、6月7日放送の第10話の前に、第9話が来週水曜日正午まで限定公開中です。
まだ見ていないかたはぜひチェックして、最新話の放送に備えてください。
今週日曜日の朝9時30分からは第10話が放送されますので、お楽しみに。
おもちゃ情報も充実しています。
アニメにも登場するオネガイアイプリ バニティカードボックスが話題です。
ミラーパクトやカードを約500枚収納できる大容量で、ハードケース仕様なので安心して使えます。
おしゃれで実用的なグッズとして人気です。
続いてキングオブプリズム関連のニュースです。
6月5日からキングオブプリズム ホワイトベアカフェのコラボグッズの予約販売が始まりました。
販売期間は7月20日までとなっています。
さらにキングオブプリズム 10周年記念展 ～ロード トゥ ザ ドラマティック フューチャー～の事後通販もアモカフェウェブショップでスタートしました。
イベントに行けなかったかたもこの機会にぜひチェックしてください。
また、6月30日までキングオブプリズム～ジュエルコレクション～くじも好評販売中です。
新規描き下ろし衣装のキャラファイングラフやグリッター缶バッジが登場しています。
プリパラのファンのみなさんには、6月20日土曜日に開催されるスペシャルイベント、ときをこえてみんなでレッツ！
プリパライブ★の配信チケット販売開始をお知らせします。
会場は立川ステージガーデンで、おうちから何度でも楽しめる配信チケットは今から購入可能です。
プリパラの熱いライブをぜひ体験してください。
最後に、ワッチャプリマジ！
のスペシャルイベント情報です。
8月29日土曜日に開催されるワッチャプリマジ！
スペシャルイベント～ワッチャ！
5th！
マジック！
～の追加キャストが発表され、公式ホームページで最終先行受付が始まりました。
人気キャラクター、ジェニファー・純恋・ソル役の声優、青野紗穂さんの出演が決定しています。
チケットは6月21日まで受付中ですので、興味のあるかたはお早めにお申し込みください。
今日は大きな新情報は少なめですが、各シリーズのイベントやキャンペーンが続々と動き出しています。
オネガイアイプリのサンリオコラボカードやキングオブプリズムのグッズ通販、プリパラのライブ配信チケット、ワッチャプリマジのイベント先行受付など、みんなの注目が集まる話題が満載です。
以上、今日のプリティーシリーズニュースでした。